wir haben es gerade gemeldet die
absolute horror meldung während das
ozonloch immer kleiner wird wird die
ozonschicht immer dünner
eine forschungsgruppe vermutet illegale
quellen von fckw und die new york times
hat sie jetzt aufgespürt klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen das
ist wirklich eine sehr sehr schlimme
situation die ozonschicht schwindet und
wir menschen sind der uv-strahlung aus
dem weltall hilflos ausgesetzt sie
verursacht hautkrebs und wer genauer
hinschaut der sieht auch bei mir hier im
gesicht eine narbe
das war ein basaliom hautkrebs ich bin
ein opfer dieser entwicklung gewesen und
damit sich die ozonschicht wieder
regeneriert und das nicht weiter
passiert wurde schon vor geraumer zeit
gegen die verursacher vorgegangen flur
kohlenwasserstoff fckw er zerstört die
ozonschicht glücklicherweise ist der
verbrauch und auch die produktion seit
dem montrealer abkommen um rund 90
prozent zurückgegangen
damals hat man beschlossen dieses gas zu
verbieten
doch eine schnelle erholung der
ozonschicht ist dennoch nicht zu
erwarten das sagt die weltorganisation
für meteorologie wmo
denn die schädlichen chemikalien die
bauen sich extrem langsam ab eine zahl
macht allerdings hoffnung denn der
ozongehalt der atmosphäre habe sich seit
2000 stabilisiert so studien bisher aber
das scheint nicht wirklich der fall zu
sein eine studie aus der schweiz vom
dortigen physikalisch meteorologischen
observatorium in davos hat nämlich das
gegenteil heraus gefunden und die
ergebnisse sind absolut besorgnis
erregend denn diese studie zeigt dass
das ozonloch zwei mal kleiner wird doch
die ozonschicht über den tropen und den
mittleren breiten dünnt weiter aus das
fazit der forschungsgruppe ist
alarmierend denn es zeigt dass die
ozonschicht noch nie so dünn gewesen ist
wie heute die schädlichen fckw sind wohl
noch längst nicht geschichte alte
kühlgeräte werden noch längst nicht auf
der ganzen welt ordnungsgemäß recycelt
ein forschungsteam aus den usa äußert
die vermutung dass irgendwo heimlich
noch größere mengen an fckw produziert
werden
durch die analyse
verschiedene messmethoden schließen sie
darauf dass die gestiegenen emissionen
in südostasien lokalisiert werden können
und jetzt hat die new york times die
verursacher aufgespürt und was da
passiert das ist wirklich ziemlich
schlimm
demnach setzen illegale kühlschrank
produzenten in ostchina das verbotenen
tree chlor flur methan ein gas das eben
zu den verbotenen flur
kohlenwasserstoffen gehört die
kühlschrank produzenten sparen mit dem
auf dem schwarzmarkt besorgten gas bares
geld und verwenden es deshalb weiter die
new york tanz spürte die kühlschrank
produzenten in der küstenprovinz
shandong auf wo in den fabriken die
isolationsschicht von kühlschränken mit
dem gas aufgespannt wird der
chinesischen regierung ist das problem
wohl auch seit längerem bekannt aber
lokale parteifunktionäre scheinen die
produzenten wohl zu schützen und zudem
werden die fabriken wohl nicht
angemeldet und ziehen um wenn sie
entdeckt werden seit januar gibt es neue
handelsregeln für vorprodukte von drei
kilometern
ob das die produktion einnehmen wird und
diese dramatische entwicklung stoppen
wird das ist allerdings mehr als
fraglich wenn ihr keine videos dazu und
zu allen themen ich hatte euch natürlich
immer auf dem laufenden verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht
er die kaputte am boxi auf youtube und
verpasst kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social and media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch drauf klicken
der vorbericht horrormeldung die
ozonschicht ist so dünn wie noch nie bis
dann bleibt dran